okay so Ted lasso is my fix for
everything having a bad day turn on some
Ted to cheer me up having a great day
let's turn on some Ted to celebrate and
because I can never get enough of
hearing Ted Talk hey now I took a look
at some fun behind the scenes action of
this awesome series here we go hey hold
my beard
he's here he's there he's every bleep
and where Roy Kent if you're a fan of
the show you've probably joined in on
that chant within the first few words
let's be honest as far as chance go it's
a banger but when you picture Good Old
Roy you'll probably see actor Brett
goldstein's face and he's probably
shouting the f word in every sentence
and yet he's somehow like the most
lovable character on the show or maybe
like the top three I don't know everyone
on Ted lasso is freaking adorbs but what
I recently found out is that Brett
wasn't even supposed to play Roy Kent he
was actually a writer on the show before
he landed the part and he admitted that
while they were writing the first few
apps he was envisioning himself in the
role even though he knew none of the
other writers were yet but after they
finish the scripts he actually taped
himself doing a few of the scenes and
then he sent it to the producers dang
that's getting after it and it worked
they totes agreed with him and we're all
bleeping grateful that they did speaking
of inspired casting it turns out Juno
Temple's character Keeley Jones was
actually inspired by a real person named
wanna guess did you guess Keely well
done you Keeley Hazel an actress and a
model was already a friend of Jason
sudeikis's and he decided she'd make for
a great character he Loosely based Keely
Jones on her and perhaps as a sign of
his gratitude he also gave her a part on
the show she plays Bax the fiance of
ex-richmond owner and general not so
great guy Rupert you have to wonder if
that's the first time in TV history that
a person inspired a character and then
acted opposite that character as a
completely different character I'd look
it up but honestly I don't even know how
I would phrase it I've already given up
and I'm gonna go eat a snack while I do
maybe you can hit that subscribe button
to catch more vids like this one but
speaking of snackage did you know that
those biscuits Ted always brings Rebecca
are in real life pretty awful it's a
little heartbreaking if I'm being real
with you guys I always imagine those
biscuits are like a little slice of
magic and that Hannah waddingham who
plays Rebecca ruins takes because she's
like enjoying them too much that
particular bubble of mine Burst when I
heard that there to her like sticking a
piece of sponge in her face Say It Ain't
So Rebecca or I guess since Rebecca is
like a proper English woman Say It Isn't
So apparently Hannah considers the
process of pretending the biscuits taste
amazing as the best acting she does on
the show but since she's great in pretty
much every scene I guess she's just
multi-talented another multi-talented
performer on the show is Christo
Fernandez he plays the ever bubbly Danny
Rojas the man whose skills rescued the
team in their lowest points and shooting
his scenes on the pitch was probably
slightly easier on the production team
because Christo is actually a former pro
footballer so he's like not faking it at
all he played in Liga MX in Mexico for
the team tecos and while he wasn't quite
good enough to make it in the top levels
of the sport he certainly was good
enough to fake it for Apple TV although
I also found out that most of the
players on the team played at least in
high school if not college too so
there's not really any actors on the FC
Richmond Squad that are totally faking
it another thing that was totally not
faked was when Ted lasso hit his head on
Rebecca's door frame according to Jason
Sudeikis that moment looked so real well
because it was he nailed the top of his
head on her frame as he jumped out of
her office but it wasn't in the script
for him to hurt himself he accidentally
jumped a bit too high and ended up
splitting his head open they had to use
super glue to seal it shut because the
dang thing was gushing like a geyser
Jason knew he'd actually hit his head
when he did the take but he didn't
realize he'd hit it quite so hard he
reached up there to check on it and saw
a little drop of blood so for a second
he didn't think it was too too bad but
then a moment later there was like a
pool of blood on the ground next to him
so yeah that's commitment to the part
y'all and of course all the actors are
committed to their parts some have even
committed to a couple of them the role
of Higgins is daf a fan favorite and
Jeremy Swift plays him brilliantly with
a perfect mix of nerdy and wise it
wouldn't have surprised me if Swift was
like the first person who got cast
because he seems to fit the role so
perfectly but it turns out they actually
took a look at some other auditioners
namely Jamie tart and Nate yep Phil
dunster who plays Jamie tart and Nick
Muhammad who plays former assistant
coach Nate both read for the role of
Higgins now I can sort of see Nick
Muhammad in that role because he plays
meek and good-hearted so well especially
early on in Nate's story but I was
floored thinking about Phil dunster not
only playing Higgins but not playing
Jimmy tart I also can't help but think
of the name Phil Dunphy when I hear his
name but that's probably because I
recently binged Modern Family not
something you need to worry about the
producers did need to worry about the
scene where the team does karaoke and
Rebecca sings Let It Go not because of
Hannah wanting him singing she clearly
sings like an angel and I won't hear
otherwise but because Disney wasn't
super into them using that song in the
show and by not super into I mean they
said no but in a smart move the Ted
lasso team went ahead and had her do a
take with that song anyway they also
filmed one with her singing I will
survive when they sent the finished
scene with Let It Go in there Disney was
all oh yeah just kidding so they were
able to use the song okay I'm gonna go
try to make some biscuits that don't
taste like sponge and I probably will
sing Let It Go because Disney has no
rights over what I belt out off-key in
my kitchen you guys if you know of any
other fun BTS gold from Ted lasso hit up
the comments section
thank you